have you thought about making putting a
ring on
it yeah R you want to cut that out no
she she knows I I've already got the
engagement ring oh wow did she know that
she kind of knows it I told her like I
put a down payment for it and like it's
getting
like like made you know what I mean cuz
her SI her size is like a three and a
half super tiny so you can't just go to
like zel's and get a ring for her you
know you got to get it custom so my
friend at Barnett jewelry is U making
her a ring but I just got to you know
find the right place to drop the knee
you
know yeah so I'm just waiting for that
I'm not going to do it on my surf tour
in Hawaii I'm like you know what I mean
so right you just want to make sure that
you're
stealth yeah I want to surprise her you
know so she keeps asking like where's I
just want it now you know what I mean
she says she wants the ring now
yeah wow so she I mean she wants to get
married to you now yeah yeah she she
wants to get married which is so cool
like she puts up with me you know and
like not a lot of people can do that you
know well and she stayed with you
through this like downward she's like
the ride or die you know what I mean she
is the one did she sleep with you in the
in the U-Haul no no no once I lost my
apartment she kind of we kind of like we
were talking but when w't really hanging
out you know you paid like 20 bucks a
day for the U-Haul yeah 20 bucks a day
my bill came out to like 1,800 bucks at
the end of it it was like a month and a
half yeah it was kind of just like
paying rent yeah kind of
yeah just
electricity water oh yeah I mean sleep
in your own sewage and come to think of
it as kind of a bad deal
for sure where were you like where would
you [__] like I saw a video you you was
I was [__] like shoe box yeah okay I
saw think about you [__] in shoe
boxes yeah or like I'd used my Dad's
apartment okay that's good wait what was
your rock
bottom it New Year's not the U-Haul or
[__] and shoe box it was phone
charger phone charger San Jose
homeless begging for change who's the
how did the guy take your
U-Haul were you hanging out with them
before yeah we were supposed to go up to
Sacramento to get a van and turn in my
U-Haul so I could live in his van and by
Van you mean meth no so this guy I was
with I never did drugs with him really
yeah but he was on something like I
don't know if he was taking pills or
whatnot but I never did drugs with him
and like I think he's like kind of manic
and like a little bit out there you know
yeah and you were just hanging out with
them up there well I seen him at State
Beach at my low at the parking lot in
State Beach yeah and then you're like oh
dude what up yeah he kind of like he you
know kind of like he kind of like thinks
he's a rapper how long did it take for
you guys to hang out for him to steal
from you to steal the U-Haul the the
U-Haul got taken
because I was staying at a friend's
house and this guy I was with in the
U-Haul cuz I I was like just hop in my
U-Haul you know we'll go up to
Sacramento and grab his his van had on
his
property and um so he was overstaying at
a friend's house in San Jose and the my
friend worked at 6:00 a.m. in the
morning so I stayed the night there he
went to the U-Haul to sleep in the
U-Haul and I came out that morning and
the U-Haul was gone wow and you never
saw it again he turned it in for me oh
where he took all my stuff out and
turned it in oh so he did you a huge
favor yeah oh kind of yeah oh okay how
you get back home but then he didn't
though because he wasn't answering his
phone he left me on the streets well
how'd you get back home he finally came
with a Suburban he got from his property
in Sacramento with all my stuff in it
and picked me up at this hotel cuz I
called my dad I was like Dad I'm [__]
stuck in San Jose he got me a hotel that
night so I wasn't freezing in the
streets and then the guy finally came
dude the guy never freaking slept and I
ever did drugs with the guy I was like
what is this guy on dude and he freaking
drove to Sacramento and back to San Jose
dropped off the U-Haul put all all my
stuff in his
suburban and picked me up the next day
and we drove back to Carl's Bad and
that's when I reached out for
help Jesus Christ wow so wait he woke up
maybe he just woke up he was like on
meth and he was like I'm not waiting for
this guy to wake up I'll just do the
trip on my own yeah it was weird though
cuz I never like we never did met
together I don't know what he was on but
he's just not a sharer like like your
other bro he's probably just closet
tweaker like I'm not going to let him
know I have some he's goingon to smoke
it
all what was Hannah doing when you were
going through all that um she was not
talking to me um yeah so and then I so
then when I lost Grom back to the Grom
story when I lost Grom her friend sent
her a picture of the lost lost dog thing
and she called me where's Gro I go I
lost them and then I found them and then
she's like I want to like I was at State
Beach and she was like down the street I
guess and she came and saw me and that's
when she's like you need like you need
to tell me what's going on like I was
like all right well I've been freaking
on math for the last eight months and
she's like I knew you're on something
like and then she's like if you want
want to be with me you need to get
professional help and you need to
freaking go to rehab and like get your
[__]
together so she's a ride or die she's a
r or die so she's been through the whole
me freaking being in a U-Haul to now
where I'm sober and she's the best she
supports my sobriety
100% And yeah we have a great life now
yeah and I just I support whatever she
wants to do and yeah we love each other
very very much do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is sto's butt
wipes for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and sto's butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah years